the Irving G Thalberg Memorial Award is
a living tribute to a man whose life
seems to have left from the pages of a
script they called Irving the Boy Wonder
he was the son of Jewish immigrants who
arrived in Brooklyn with less than a
dollar to their name and before he
turned 10 doctors told her vines parents
that he wouldn't live to see 30 they
worried about the strength of his heart
what they failed to consider was the
power of his creative soul and the depth
of his passion and this is what drove
her vein to Hollywood where he rose to
become the head of production for MGM at
the Eldar age of 25 and then went on to
produce some 400 films introducing the
world to talent like Joan Crawford Clark
Gable and Greta Garbo and helping to
create a foundation for the art form
that we honor tonight along the way it
was Hollywood that introduced Thalberg
to the love of his life his wife Norma
Shearer so cut to tonight as we gather
to honor the first ever married couple
to receive the Faubourg award my forever
friends the inseparable the indomitable
Kathleen Kennedy and Frank Marshall
Kathy is the first woman ever to receive
this award in history which is her
hallmark the breaker of glass ceilings
were ever she sets her sights including
now as master of the universe and
galaxies far far away and for those of
you wondering why it's taken so long for
the Academy to celebrate Kathy with this
honor you should know it's completely
her fault because she has been such a
faithful Academy officer year after year
that she was ineligible until now and a
person it didn't always seem so
preordained because back in the day
before dinosaurs and CGI and otherwise
there was a time when assistants were
referred to as secretaries and mine was
Kathy she sat outside my office and I
had often invite her in to take notes
during writers pitching sessions but
here was the problem she rarely took a
note as a matter of fact she often took
over the meeting pitching her own ideas
which were great so I hired a secretary
for Kathy and she went from taking notes
to taking over we were a team now and we
were preparing prepping Raiders of the
Lost Ark and Kathy's title had rapidly
risen to associate producer and it was
all going so well and then I hired a guy
named Frank because I was looking for a
line producer for Raiders and in walked
this handsome hotshot with a resume the
would have likely read ski bum waiter a
guitar player
this is the guy who created UCLA's first
n-c-double-a soccer team and then played
on it and this is a guy who met Peter
Bogdanovich at John Ford's birthday
party you can't make this stuff up and
went off to serve his location manager
for the last picture show and for Marty
Scorsese's The Last Waltz and then
associate producing for Walter Hill
Frank part rogue part Renaissance man he
was a star on the rise that in his blood
were the boots on the ground of an
online producer and therefore just a man
for this job so there we were Frank and
Cathy and me and from Raiders onward we
founded Apple Entertainment and we made
movie after movie together until one day
when I walked into my office and saw the
two of them making out on my couch
[Applause]
and and and for work from where I stood
and what I saw suddenly I'm the third
wheel we were still three but they were
two and that spark between them has lit
a torch that burns bright in movie
history as you've just seen stories that
remind us popular and powerful can live
together and do live together in movies
that echo across time and it's important
side note to say that Cathy and Frank
have also made movies separately just
one example of many Cathy's first
producing credit was this little film
called et and Frank has credits that
include all three Jurassic world film's
producer of Clint Eastwood Sully and as
Matt said the Jason Bourne franchise and
Frank then even donned before that his
director's cap to film movies like
arachnophobia and alive
so neat I say that this dynamic duo now
married for 31 years
may claim their finest producing effort
as their wonderful daughters lily and
Megan
a film historian once described Irving
Thalberg as temperate in all his ways of
living in this one respect he was an
inveterate gambler if he believed in a
man or a woman or a project or a story
he would stake everything on this
conviction and again and again Cathy and
Frank had been those kind of creative
producers the dreamers who saw in
scripts so much of the spark they saw in
each other
the power to pull us in with the
potential to steal our hearts so I
couldn't be prouder to be their third
wheel I couldn't be luckier to be their
friend and I couldn't be more humbled to
stand up here tonight to present this
year's recipients of the Irving G
Thalberg m'm worl award to Kathleen
Kennedy and Frank Marshall
[Applause]